c'est vendredi à 17h45
françois bayrou le président du
mouvement démocrate est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous bien venu sur le plateau de
public sénat pour notre rendez vous
réalisez comme chaque semaine en
partenariat avec dailymotion et puis l'
agence france presse qui sera représenté
dans quelques instants ici par notre
confrère pierre rockit sur l'île perrine
tarneaud de public sénat bien sûr nous
rejoindra en fin d'émission avant
d'évoquer bien sûr la situation
économique sociale et politique nous
parlons d'abord si vous le voulez bien
françois bayrou de l affaire tapie
l'homme d'affaires a été rejoint par son
avocat maurice lantourne dans sa garde à
vue ce que vous avez le sentiment que la
justice avec ses mises en examen répéter
pour escroquerie en bande organisée
vous donne peu à peu raison il est
indiscutable que la justice avance et il
paraît indiscutable qu'elle avance dans
la direction de cette gigantesque
manipulation dont tout le monde
aujourd'hui même les plus incrédules
voit la gravité par une série de
rebondissements qui s'il était présenté
dans un roman donnerait à tout le monde
a pensé l'idée que vraiment ce une
imagination trop fertile de la part du
scénariste qui comme je le dis depuis le
premier jour sera à mes yeux si c'est
prouvé sera la sphère la plus grave de
la vème république une affaire mais
table une fraction là on l'utilisé
norvégien jeu l'utilisent depuis cinq
ans parce qu'il n'y a aucun doute que
contrairement à ce qui est présenté
la question ce n'est pas bernard tapie
par un tapis c'est un homme de dhafer
comme on dit c'est à dire un homme d'
aventure un homme de de flibuste quand
il faut mais ça n'est pas lui le
l'auteur de cette affaire il se défend
lui l'auteur de cette affaire et qui
sait l'état
c'est au sein de l'état abbas a demandé
le juge
c'est au sein de l'ehf a fait au niveau
de l'état que cette affaire a été
acceptée voulue et organisée et tout le
monde le sait je veux dire il n'y a plus
désormais aucun doute on a même
découvert des réunions de préparation
participé d'un art tapie lui-même à
l'élise ailleurs en qu'il a prétendu à
plusieurs reprises que ça n'était pas
vrai mais vous voyez bien la différence
qu'il faut faire ça n'est pas bernard
tapie contre un certain nombre de alerte
de l'ensemble alerte c'est
l'organisation de l'état qui par son le
sentiment d'impunité qui était le sien
la désinvolture à l'égard du droit
le fait qu'on ne respecte plus en france
les principes ou qu'on ne respectait
plus les principes mêmes la légalité
formelle qui a entraîné cette situation
dans laquelle le contribuable c'est à
dire vous et tout ce qu'ils nous
entendent ont été spoliés de plus de 400
millions d'euros au profit d'intérêts
privés dont on ne voit pas très bien le
périmètre d'ailleurs aujourd'hui alors
donc il faut préciser les choses là où
on a compris que tout était conçu ce
selon vous à l'élysée d'ailleurs les
justes se rapproche effectivement tôt
l'elysée mais nous sommes dans les 2008
a été conçu à lui tout est vu néons les
réunions ce n'est pas cette analyse se
faisons attention à ce que nous disons
tout a été voulu approuver et organiser
conçu on sait pas encore très bien qui a
eu l'imagination la capacité de
concevoir ce système mais en tout cas
l'elysée a donné son approbation aucun
doute selon vous la mobile
mais tout ça j'ignore quelle est elle
vous avez des idées par ailleurs tout
cas je ne je ne crois pas du tout à
plusieurs des pistes qui ont été
évoquées
l'idée qu'il s'agirait d'une récompense
politique pour un soutien politique
donnée en 2007 jean croit pas un mot
je ne crois pas un mot qu'il y ait une
entente politique avec des courants je
crois pas du tout d'autres hypothèses
ont été formulées sur votre plateau je
ne je ne sais pas je n'ai au aucun
élément n'est pas moi je fleurs compte
infernal tapis écoutez j'ai écrit un
livre sur ce sujet dans laquelle il ya
deux hypothèses principales où je
retient deux hypothèses principales la
première ces dépressions bernard tapie
peut avoir eu le moyen de faire pression
sur le pouvoir et la deuxième c'est que
au fond le chapitre du livre que j'ai
consacré à cette affaire s'appelle
l'arbitraire au fond l'idée que parce
qu'on est dans l'orbité du pouvoir en a
tous les droits et si on est hors de
leurs beats on en a aucun cette idée est
au fond celle de de tous ceux qui
cultivent le pouvoir absolu et peut-être
que simplement on a dit arrangé pour
cette affaire d'accord et au bout du
compte les l'image de la république
l'idée même de la république et de
l'état et les intérêts des plus pauvres
ont été mises à mal gravement
alors bernard tapie mais aussi de
publier un livre dans quelques jours sur
cette affaire
le livret est titré un scandale d'état
oui mais pas celui qu'il vous raconter
dans cet ouvrage il vous épargne
d'ailleurs vous avez su encore le
distinguo entre la sphère et demi il ya
un instant sur ce plateau françois
bayrou et lui se présente en volley qui
serait donc devenu le voleur il se
présente envolé dans le coup de génie de
bernard tapie c'est d'avoir réussi à
persuader un grand nombre de personnes
que il avait été victime lui même dans
cette affaire au début de la sphère en
92 et je crois que les éléments de
preuve sont innombrables
pour montrer que c'est absolument le
contraire le crédit lyonnais n'est pas
venu pour lui pour le spolier le crédit
lyonnais est venu pour le sauver sur
injonction directe du pouvoir de
l'époque c'est à dire c'est plus vers
l'or de françois mitterrand en charge
change hélas pas si vous me permettez
c'est qu'à l'époque je suis un jeune
député de l'opposition et j'interpelle
le gouvernement en disant il est
totalement inacceptable qu'une banque
nationalisée viennent faire des affaires
avec un ministre en poste et vous
comprenez bien ça veut dire prise
illégale d'intérêts ça veut dire qu'on
l'a encore on respecte pas les principes
et vous voyez que au fond ce qui est en
cause au travers du temps gouvernement
mitterrand gouvernement de la dernière
période sapin c'est une certaine idée de
l'absolutisme du pouvoir qui est en
cause je fais ce que je veux parce que
là où on décide de tout et tout le monde
obéir à ça s'est passé en 92 pour le
le rachat d'une entreprise qui était au
bord de la liquidation est plutôt sur la
pente la plus glissante de la
liquidation et ça s'est passé de la même
manière pour cet arbitrage complètement
abracadabra l'or aujourd'hui des recours
sont engagés par l'état contre cet
arbitrage est ce qu on mesure bien quand
même est-ce que vous même vous mesurez
bien les dangers de cette nouvelle
procédure qui va être très long sur une
équipe
c'est complètement faux ah bon ça c'est
le passé
c'est un des éléments de la
mystification sera longue mais bale est
longue elle est longue
c'est peut-être moins qu'on ne croit
mais je voudrais dire quelque chose sous
forme d'avertissement
il n'y a rien de plus facile que de
perdre un recours il suffit de mal
choisir les arguments de mal le formuler
ne pas être dans les formes parce que
c'est c'est subtil les formes d'un
recours de cet ordre il s'agit de 400
millions d'euros et donc j'imagine
qu'ils à des juristes puissant dans
l'entourage du gouvernement
je demande qu'on fasse attention à la
manière dont le recours sera présenté et
formuler dont l'état puisque derrière
cette maison de liquidation du crédit
lyonnais il y à l'état c'est le
contribuable qui paie jusqu'à la
dernière minute que l'état soit plus
précautionneux cette fois plus prudents
cette fois qu'il ne l'a été dans les 2
épisodes précédents les français ne
tolérerait pas que cette affaire soit
mal conduite
j'espère que que mes craintes
n'ont pas de fondement mais les joueurs
de droit d ordre juridique sur le choix
des avocats par exemple qui pourrait
être mêlé à négocier voilà mais bon vous
croyez quand même à la détermination
politique s'il n'y a pas de
détermination politique là alors il n'y
a plus qu'à tirer l'échelle n'est ce pas
le on est devant la révélation qui a été
nié par beaucoup de monde pendant
longtemps à l'intérieur de l'état la
révélation d'un teint d'une offense
faite à tous nos principes
quelque chose qui quand ce sera connue
révoltera les citoyens au-delà du
possible il est du devoir des
responsables de l'état de faire ce qu'il
faut pour que l'intérêt général soit
protégé vous croyez donc à la
détermination du gouvernement dans ce
dossier est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir aussi une orchestration
politique 1-2 ce recompte de cette
affaire c'est ce qu'on entend par
exemple à l'ump
d'où leur parent qui a dénoncé une
justice spectacle d'autres proches de
nicolas sarkozy qui disent que tout ça
c'est fait pour barrer la route un
éventuel retour de nicolas phare du sud
reçu ressasser le jeu de rôle politique
l'opposition dit regardez c'est la faute
du gouvernement et le gouvernement dira
regardez c'est la faute de l'opposition
moi je ne suis pas dans ce jeu de rôle
j'essaie d'être représentants de ces
citoyens qui n'en peuvent plus qu'ils ne
peuvent pas accepter que durent ces
pratiques
et donc ma conviction profonde c'est
qu'il n'ya aucune manipulation politique
s'il y avait quelque chose à dire de la
gauche pendant les années où nous avons
mené le combat c'est qu'elle a été
indulgente pendant longtemps pour les
raisons que tout le monde voit bien
c'était le gouvernement mitterrand sur
la fin certain nombre de responsables
politiques dont par ironie jérôme
cahuzac qui a été alors c'est une ironie
de l'histoire mais un certain nombre de
responsables politiques du parti
socialiste sur la fin ont pris leurs
responsabilités
au début il y en avait très peu pour ne
pas dire qu'il n'y en avait aucun est-ce
que les affaires peuvent empêcher un
jour nicolas sarkozy de revenir
je ne suis pas je ne veux pas aborder
cette question parce que
comprenez nous n'avons pas fait tout
cela les quelques-uns la petite poignée
nous n'avons pas fait tout cela pour des
raisons politiciennes c'est pas parce
que j'étais contre nicolas sarkozy
d'abord j'ai jamais été contre un homme
j'ai été contre la politique qu'il
menait les choix qu'il faisait mais
c'était pas contre quelqu'un c'était que
sous nos yeux sous les yeux de tous les
français en tout cas ce qui aurait dû
être sous les yeux de tous les français
permettez moi de dire au passage que les
médias aussi ont leur part de
responsabilité parce que il y avait un
très grand scepticisme à l'égard de ce
que nous disions et vous le savez bien
et bien sous les yeux de tous les
français étaient en train de se
perpétrer quelque chose qui était une
offense absolue à notre pacte civique
cela j'étais responsable de l'éducation
civique des jeunes français j'ai une
petite idée de ce qu'on doit transmettre
est enseignée est d'abord par l'exemple
et ça commence l'éducation civique
quand ceux qui sont en haut se comporte
de manière respectable jetons maastricht
je vis même pas exemplaire voyage
le mot a été tellement utilisée par
d'autres en tous cas de manière
respectable utiliser un terme fort ma
photo est ce qu'il faut en france que
des scandales éclatent régulièrement
pour que l'on prenne le chemin n'est
qu'un cas est de la probité je pense par
exemple on voit de loin sur la
transparence et quand ça monte ce qu a
dit quelque chose au fond nous avons la
chance d'avoir les plus grands
philosophes de la démocratie en france
et il ya trois siècles bientôt deux
siècles
oui notre cinq bateaux montesquieu a dit
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
frappant il a dit il n'y a qu'une
manière de modérer l'absolutisme
c'est la séparation des pouvoirs et
c'est lui qui a le premier indiqué ce
que pouvait être ces trois pouvoirs au
mois parce que la presse est maintenant
le quatrième pouvoir
si vous avez une presse indépendante une
justice libre ou une presse libre une
justice indépendante et la séparation
des pouvoirs entre une assemblée et un
gouvernement
l'une l'assemblée contrôlant l'autre le
gouvernement alors vous avez des
probabilités et même probablement des
chances d'avoir un gouvernement honnête
alors françois bayrou pierre qui tient
ni de l' agence france-presse va nous
rejoindre maintenant nous allons parler
de votre engagement européen et de votre
appel il ya quelques jours qu'ils
sortent il faut se dire un euro
scepticisme croissant illustré encore
cette semaine par un nouveau clash entre
paris et berlin et bruxelles avec marie
vraiment aux brasseurs surtout entre
paris bruxelles dans l'espace disputer
pour son franc parler et ses envolées
une fois encore arnaud montebourg le
médiatique ministre de l'industrie tape
fort
la victime est coutumière des critiques
l'union européenne et son dirigeant le
monsieur barroso est le carburant du
front national voilà la vérité il est le
carburant de beppe grillo une phrase
assassine à l'encontre du président de
la commission européenne accusée de tous
les maux par une gauche qui frôle
l'euroscepticisme benoît hamon bruno le
roux claude bartolone jean-christophe
cambadélis harlem désir
mais là plus personne ne tente de sauver
les apparences et la communication passe
désormais par médias interposés auberger
montebourg
voilà donc la réponse sanglante de la
bergère c'est quand il s'agit de
réformes économiques
quand il s'agit d' ouverture quand il
s'agit de mondialisation quand il s'agit
de l'europe et de ses institutions
certains souverainistes de gauche et
l'extrême droite ont exactement le même
discours
t c'est pas les autres qui vont revenir
c'est par bruxelles s'est pas
berlin qui va venir faire les réformes
dont la france a besoin
et voilà pourquoi aussi faux que les
ministres soient responsables l'europe
bouc émissaire c'est toujours la même
rengaine est particulièrement en période
de groove
il ya beaucoup plus de critiques de
l'europe dans les pays qui vont mal
comme la france que dans les pays qui
vont mieux
comme l'allemagne depuis plusieurs mois
le torchon brûle entre paris et
bruxelles les désaccords quotidien entre
l'austère allemagne et la france
dépensière ou encore l'exception
culturelle ont abîmé une image déjà
dégradée de l'union européenne un an des
futures élections
c'est difficile de taper sur l'europe
toute la semaine devant dès le dimanche
aux européennes voté oui à l'europe
ça c'est clair donc il ya un risque le
risque c'est l'abstention où la montée
des extrêmes au sein du parlement
européen
mais qui dit nouveau parlement européen
dit également commission renouvelée et
nouveau président les jours de josé
manuel barosso sont donc comptés même à
droite il cristallise les critiques
alain juppé l'a qualifié d' archaïque
sa succession est clairement ouverte aux
questions à françois bayrou bonsoir
alors la première question c'est est ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut encore
échapper à un raz-de-marée des
eurosceptiques landes la prochaine
élection européenne oui ça dépend d'une
seule chose est ce que ceux qui croient
l'europe vital pour notre pays sont
capables de se battre ou seulement de
courber le dos d'être honteux de
chercher ddd stratégie de fuite d'être
au fond d
des renégats d'une certaine manière de
ce qui a été
l'idée fondamentale de notre nation
pendant 60 ans et l'idée fondamentale
qui a fait de la france ce qu'elle est
si vous remontez le temps chaque fois
que la france a été isolée elle s'est
effondrée chaque fois que la france a
été fermé elle s'est effondrée alors
bien sûr il y à une vague
d'euroscepticisme ou même de colère
contre l'europe
on sait d'ailleurs très souvent c'est
parce qu'il y à la recherche d'un
responsable d'un bouc émissaire de
quelqu'un qu'on peut mettre en
accusation de alors qu'ils portent
aucune responsabilité n'est ce pas quel
est le responsable des problèmes de la
france
pour moi le responsable des problèmes de
la france et la france c'est à dire ça
n'est pas parce que l'europe existe et
qu'elle réunit des pays qui cherchent
ensemble un chemin c'est pas parce que
l'europe existe que nous n'apprenons pas
à lire à nos enfants c'est pas parce que
l'europe existe que nous avons de
l'insécurité dans nos quartiers c'est
pas parce que l'europe existe que
l'intégration ne marche pas atteint 10
francs celle ci leur laissez moi finir
le rock à la croissance n'est pas là
mais c'est pas vrai ça n'est pas parce
que l'europe existe que les promesses
des politiques sont illusoires
ça n'est pas parce que l'europe existe
que il ya de la corruption comme on
vient d'en parler dans la vie politique
française
tout ça au contraire d'une certaine
manière l'europe et c'est comme elle
peut et pas toujours idéalement de
lutter contre mais vous voyez bien à
quel point c'est une diversion
au fond ce que font ce que fait le parti
socialiste aujourd'hui et un certain
nombre de membres du gouvernement vient
de le voir
que font-ils il cherche à détourner
l'attention des responsabilités qu'ils
peuvent être les leurs on peut pas dire
que depuis un an la situation économique
du pays se soient améliorées n'est ce
pas et donc ils chef contrairement à ce
que
je pense est nécessaire il cherche à
détourner l'attention et a préparé un
combat électoral qui est un combat une
nouvelle fois caricatural qui
chercheraient à expliquer que le vrai
combat c'est en europe la gauche contre
la droite et c'est complètement faux la
question c'est la seule question qui se
pose qui se posent à notre pays et
michel barnier vient de le dire à sa
manière nous disons même chose la seule
question qui se pose à notre pays c est
ce que nous sommes capables nous
français de réparer les dégâts que nous
avons laissé se faire est ce que nous
sommes capables de reconstruire ce qui
doit l'être et ma réponse est que nous
en sommes capables
à condition qu'il y ait une prise de
conscience et une volonté qui se forment
ces phrases sont fait pour empêcher la
prise de conscience et la volonté de se
former alors si les héros sceptiques
étaient uniquement au front national au
front de gauche pour moi la limite mais
là on les trouve aujourd'hui à l'ump on
les retrouve au cs on les retourne
rieuse ump on les retrouve au ps je n'ai
aucun doute de ce point de vue là et
c'est précisément pour cela que j'ai
lancé l'appel que j'ai lancé en disant
ifs
il va falloir que ceux qui considèrent
que cette question là est vital pour la
france accepte de se rapprocher les uns
des autres et de préparer le combat en
commun qu'il va falloir conduire qu'il
va falloir mener et je suis persuadé de
cela mais comme vous le savez c'est
c'est mon idée fondamentale en est
d'autres idées et nos il est impossible
pour formuler cette idée de fond il est
impossible d'apporter les réponses de
porter les réformes
de convaincre autour des réformes qui
s'imposent pour la france avec les
majorités déchiré antagonistes que nous
avons la gauche il ya au moins la moitié
de ceux qui la représentent qui sont
contre l'idée européenne et les réformes
et à droite il ya plus de la moitié
aujourd'hui deux de ceux qui sont contre
l'idée européenne et les restrictions
européens comme vous alain juppé qui
vive
il y en a assez de la vision de barroso
une concurrence sans frontières sans
limite on l'entend jean marc ayrault
très européen qui dit je ne suis pas un
béni oui oui de l'europe
biadillah il a raison moi je ne vois je
ne défends pas josé manuel barroso mes
amis ont voté contre son investiture
chaque fois mes amis ont voté contre son
investiture s'est d'ailleurs quelqu'un
de très intelligent comme vous savez
c'est un ancien maoïste qui parle très
bien notre langue qui comprend les
sujets qui est plutôt sur le versant
ultralibérale et moi je ne crois pas que
ce soit là le sujet il s'est exprimé de
manière très regrettable dans cette
affaire de l'exception culturelle
parce qu'il faut qu'ils comprennent
barroso et les autres que l'exception
culturelle c'est notre choix national
on va on va pas mettre sur le même plan
ceux qui peuvent produire un film pour 1
million 500 milliards 2 milliards 500
millions de personnes parce qu'ils sont
parce qu'il est en anglais et nous qui
n'avons que quelques 150 millions
peut-être 200 millions de locuteurs
vous voyez bien que c'est pas la même
chose de la même manière on a bien eu
raison c'est jack lang qui l'a fait de
faire le prix unique du livre le prix
unique du livre qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que que vous soyez la
petite librairie de quartier ou une
grande surface vous n'avez pas le droit
de faire du dumping sur le prix du livre
parce qu'autrement ça tue le circuit de
distribution de proximité et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire tout ça j'ai eu
l'occasion de le défendre dans un
discours samedi que vous avez suivi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
pour nous c'est une valeur fondamentale
que la quantité ne l'emportent pas sur
la qualité donc vous proposer une
certaine manière les réactions de
défiance que un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques français on
une formule et moi même il ya de vous
sur ce sujet longtemps partir je veux
pas faire de personnalité je veux pas je
veux pas personnaliser les choses par
chaque fois qu'on présente quelqu'un
comme un démon je me méfie je sais j'ai
certainement qu'est ce qu'il représente
pour vous justement manuel valeur
barroso c'est le libéralisme c'est très
longtemps cette technocratie européenne
depuis le temps où il était un homme
politique un jeune homme politique
d'opposition dans son pays
je le connais depuis le temps où il a
été premier ministre du portugal sur une
ligne qui n'est pas la mienne puisqu'il
était atlantiste il a été pour la guerre
en irak
il a été un de ses chefs de gouvernement
qui était alignée vous souvenez sur le
tarmac avec berlusconi et tony blair et
aznar pour expliquer qu'il fallait aller
derrière les américains en irak
et comme vous savez je suis monté à la
tribune moi qui étais en délicatesse
disons avec jacques chirac pour dire
qu'ils avaient raison et dont et pour
soutenir la position qui était la sienne
y compris contre un certain nombre de
mes amis donc barroso c'est cette ligne
là plutôt du côté des plus forts et est
cependant je ne veux pas que on le
présente comme quelqu'un qui n'aurait
que du vice à l'intérieur de lui parce
que ça n'est pas vrai c'est un homme
politique de premier plan
peut-être jours at il d'ailleurs un rôle
dans l'avenir de son pays à nouveau à
l'avenir
c'est un homme politique de premier plan
et mettons-nous ça en tête on peut avoir
des débats on peut avoir des désaccords
on peut avoir des conflits on peut avoir
des controverses
pour autant il n'est pas nécessaire
d'insultés et 7
cette perversion française qui consiste
à chercher à faire un ennemi personnel
de quelqu'un avec qui simplement en est
en désaccord
c'est une des faiblesses de notre pays
c'est pour ça que notre vie politique
est tellement nulle caricatural
désespérante et c'est pourquoi les
électeurs s'en sépare regardez les
questions d'actualité
quand vous voyez les questions de
l'actualité sur votre écran
eh bien vous voyez très bien que c'est
des jeux tout ça c'est des jeux de rôles
c'est la mise en scène de deux conflits
pour qu'on ne parle pas de la puissance
politique il ya des questions de fond
derrière des sujets d'affrontement
questions de fond et je jouais simple
sur la question de barroso est ce que
vous êtes vous personnellement plutôt
pour une politique de libre circulation
des hommes des idées et cetera des
marchandises ou est-ce que vous êtes
plutôt pour une europe protectrice qui
se protège derrière ses frontières que
c'est un peu sale débat exactions les
deux et si vous croyez que la protection
absolue est un progrès regardez
l'histoire de france on a fait du
protectionnisme dans les années 30 en
france en matière agricole
à quel résultat est on arrivé c'était la
politique du dénommé pays nakheel
résultat est on arrivé à la veille de la
guerre l'agriculture française
n'arrivait plus à nourrir la france
parce que vous mettez si d'ailleurs la
fermeture avait été un sujet de succès
l'allemagne de l'est aurait dominé
l'allemagne de l'ouest s'est passé
quelque chose de fascinant
on réfléchit jamais vous prenez le même
pays en 1945 dans le même état hélas
avec le même papous en tout cas un
peuple et on peut pas dire que le peuple
de l'est étaient inférieures aux peuples
de l'ouest en allemagne les landes air
orientaux et la prusse on peut pas dire
que c'était inférieur vous prenez le
même peuple en 45 vous le coupez en deux
vous mettez la protection et la
fermeture d'un côté et l'ouverture de
l'autre vous revenez 45 ans après qu'est
ce que vous trouvez d'un côté le
développement et la liberté de l'autre
la servitude et l'effondrement
économique c'est pas c'est pas un c'est
pas une thèse ce que je raconte c'est là
c'est la vérité des choses et qu'on est
en france une gauche qui veulent une
comme une extrême droite puisque lettre
ce que barroso a livré là
thèse est la même pour l'extrême gauche
et pour l'extrême droite ou pour la
gauche parce qu'il ya une partie du ps
aussi qui est sur cette ligne qui va
nous expliquer qu'il faut en revenir à
ces lunes
pour moi c'est désespérant qu'est ce que
vous diriez à ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
sceptique par rapport à la construction
européenne pour les convaincre quelles
seraient vos arguments si vous aviez
trois arguments à mettre en avant c'est
d'abord essayons de le faire sans simple
100 simplifications excessives il est
tôt on est trop loin de l'enjeu je vais
vous dire ce que je crois 1
si la france se retrouve amputée de son
soutien et des forces que l'europe lui
donne ça sera un désastre national
mais ça ne suffit pas de mettre en
valeur les menaces et les risques il
faut aussi quelque chose qui soit du
côté de l'élan de la fois ci je voulais
employer un mot sans connotation de la
foi de de l'enthousiaste de là quelque
chose qui donne envie de vivre et ça
donne envie de vivre que de partager
avec les peuples qui nous entoure moi
j'ai maintenant un petit fils belge
un de mes fils est allé et mes enfants
vivent assez souvent en italie y vivent
assez souvent dans le monde anglo saxon
et c'est les enfants de tout le monde
dans toutes les familles
le l'idée qu' on va on va remettre des
postes frontières à la frontière
espagnole
mais c'est une idée anachronique et donc
et donc l'europe est une nécessité mais
elle est pour nous une occasion de
montrer ce que la france peut faire et
c'est ça que je défendrai la la france
non seulement elle est plus forte avec
l'europe bien sûr mais ça vaut la peine
notre destin c'est que cette
civilisation européenne parce qu'il ya
une affaire de valeur derrière tout ça
rien à faire de liberté et l affaire de
culture et à une affaire de protection
des petits contre les gros qu'est ce que
c'est l'europe j'ai presque fini je vois
que vous
les comme la france s'arrête et on va
enfin quand même dire cette dernière
phrase qu'est-ce que c'est l'europe dans
le monde
c'est l'organisation politique d'état à
la tête de peuples qui ont une force
économique c'est une organisation
politique qui vient dire avec nous
l'effort n'écrase ont pas les faibles
voilà pour la profession merci pierre on
avait toutes les réponses à vos
interrogations tournent et villages et
terres de leurs bombes ont parlé dans un
instant et territoriaux qui veulent nous
rejoindre mais d'abord on s'interroge
où est passée l'idée d'une grande force
centrale alors que le clivage droite
gauche on le voit revient avec force au
profit de la crise
alors est-ce que le 3e homme voir le 2e
maintenant n'aurait pas les traits de
marine le pen
faustine sa jeunesse premier à avoir
dénoncé l' affaire tapie ou le dérapage
des comptes publics françois bayrou a
fait de la vérité en politique son
créneau mais n'a pas réussi à
reconquérir son électorat depuis son
succès en 2007
et si le président du modem avec eu
raison trop tôt
celui qui voulait incarner un centrisme
ni de gauche ni de droite n'est plus le
troisième homme largement doubler par le
front national
formé dans les rangs du modem pas
question d'entrer dans le jeu des
extrêmes qu il faut pas attendre de
françois bayrou qu'il monte aussi sur la
table pour dire on va tout casser
non la vraie carte bayrou finalement
c'est le jour où on se dira il faut qu
effectivement ceux qui sont pour la
réforme à droite à gauche et au centre
se rassemble il n'y a qu'avec cet appui
politique extrêmement large
on est capable de changer les choses
changer les choses et moraliser la vie
politique insuffisant pour florian
philippot qui dénoncent une absence
totale de programme on ne fait pas une
politique sur la dénonciation des
affaires on fait une politique sur des
propositions concrètes sur un projet
pour la france sur un cap sur un cap à 5
10 20 ans moi je ne vois pas de cap avec
le modem je ne sais pas quelle est leur
projet ou plutôt je le devine trop bien
leur projet c'est celui qui en place
l'ump le parti socialise et qui sont au
pouvoir les grandes idées ne sont plus
là les ventiler oppose le pôle je le dis
européiste communautariste de l'ump est
le pôle patriotes nationale et populaire
du front national la troisième famille
politique ce serait donc déplacé à
droite de l'échiquier comme en
témoignent les scores du fn aux
dernières élections
et pour cause dans un contexte de crise
le discours du modem serait trop modéré
les temps de crise et des temps de
fracas de protestation d'inquiétude
et dans ces temps là on préfère l'aspect
parfois un peu tonitruant que peut avoir
le front national à l'aspect plus calme
plus serein que peut avoir la le chemin
politique tente de tracer françois
bayrou mais qu'il a bien du mal à
incarner et apporter plus loin si le
message à tout pour plaire en période de
crise il semble que le style discret de
françois bayrou
elle lui a mobilisé voilà chers
internautes avec nous oui à dire un mot
sur ce reportage est seulement j'allais
vous interroger l'avenir est très
intéressant au fond que nenê de
l'imprimante crise tandis que dit le
reportage il dit cet homme là nous avait
dit la vérité sur les principaux
problèmes du pays
c'est un point deuxièmement c'est le
front national qui dit il faut avoir un
projet qui soit un projet patriotes et
national excusez moi moi je pense que le
projet du front national est un projet
anti national
parce que les choix qu'ils proposent
sortir de l'euro et revenir au franc
fermer les frontières
ce sont des choix qui conduirait la
france ô malheur je ne choisis pas les
mots au hasard je dis pas que ça serait
de mauvais choix elle qui conduirait la
france ô malheur pour toutes les
familles et pour tous les jeunes n'y a
pas de pourtant c'est c'est une
affirmation que tous ceux qui ont une
responsabilité dans le pays à laquelle
tous ceux qui ont une responsabilité
dans le pays doivent réfléchir parce que
il ya des moments dans l'histoire où il
s'agit pas de suivre les inclinations
des gens il s'agit de dire la vérité au
pays
voilà pourquoi le front national monte
en aujourd'hui parce que moi ils
arrivent ils entraient au fond d'un
électeur français bon parce que les
thèses qu'il présente qui sont des
thèses ce simple ou simpliste qui sont
déplaise mais n'essayez pas de défauts
mais ce que je sais ce que je dis
essayons de choisir les bons mots le les
français aujourd'hui sont dans une
situation d'inquiétude et on leur montre
un responsable qui est l'autre le
concurrent allemand le voisin qui nous
imposerait des choix une europe qui
viendrait nous embêter mais tout ça
c'est le contraire de ce qu'il nous faut
pour reconstruire notre pays toujours le
contraire je sais pas si j'ai le temps
de vous raconter deux très courtes
histoires courtes histoires que je
raconte dans mon livre de la vérité en
politique
dans les années 30 en angleterre il ya
une vague on appellerait ça d'extrême
droite aujourd'hui ou très à droite qui
refuse que l'angleterre participe au
grand combat européen et qui refusent de
s'armer une vague pacifiste qui dit
restons dans notre île
et puis ce qui se passe sur le continent
on veut pas le savoir il gagne les
élections
il gagnerait dans les faits il gagne un
scellé les élections il ya un homme qui
s'opposent à ça tout seul qui s'appelle
winston churchill et ils interpellent le
premier ministre est alors le premier
ministre lui répond monsieur de chercher
à excuser moi je sais bien que
l'allemagne est menaçante mais si
j'avais dit ça aux anglais pendant les
élections j'aurais perdu les élections
et qu'ils avaient raison celui qui est
allé contre la le contre le mouvement
des foules ou le contraire deuxième très
très courte histoire de gaulle revient
au pouvoir en 58
comme vous savez il s'était opposé à
l'europe beaucoup et on venait de signer
le traité de rome un an avant qui était
le traité de construction du marché
commun et tous ses conseillers et tous
ses partisans n'avaient qu'une idée
c'était de sortir de ce traité du marché
commun et de refaire les frontières on
lui propose le premier la première note
qu'on lui apporte
c'est la note pour sortir du traité de
rome et de gaulle prend son stylo et en
marge il écrit non les français sont
forts mais ils ne le savent pas et bien
cette annotation du général de gaulle
elle est valable encore aujourd'hui le
combat de churchill contre les facilités
d'aller dans le sens de l'opinion il est
valable encore aujourd hui en tout cas
pour moi c'est là qu'est la clé de notre
reconstruction nationale national par
des compatriotes patriote je suis au
moins autant qu'aucun de ceux qui
prétendent nous mettre en accusation au
moins autant et peut-être plus je n'ai
rien à redouter sur la défense de la
langue la défense de la culture la
défense de l'économie
d rien pourquoi les partis républicains
français le ps l'ump apparaissent
tétanisés face au front national
pourquoi est ce que c'est parce que le
cap affichées notamment par le
gouvernement n'est pas claire et confus
c'est parce que ce qu'on appelle un chat
puis 15 ans nous allons de dérive en
dérive et d'échecs en échecs et aux
journées nous prenons aujourd'hui
prenant éducation l'éducation moi
j'espérais que le gouvernement actuel
allait faire quelque chose qu'est ce
qu'il fait à mes yeux la sauvegarder nos
moyens d'éducation a souri eh bien il
est allé dans le sens de ce qui faisait
croire que la question est une question
de moyens et moi je vous dis c'est pas
une question de moyens c'est une
question de du système éducatif français
et de sa capacité à retrouver au fond
les forces qui ont fait qu' on a appris
à lire à tous les français pendant son
temps et que depuis quelques années on
n'y arrive plus et ça se dégrade
on annonce vous le savez une enquête
pour ces jours ci qu'ils seraient encore
plus catastrophique que les enquêtes
mais ce que françois là on vous a parlé
encore déterminé à réformer ou est-ce
qu'au contraire vous avez peur qu'ils
soient justement paralysée par ses sites
et blogs un prisonnier de sa majorité où
il se rend prisonnier de sa majorité
c'est à dire que mais la porte
non c'est pas la hauteur c'est pas c'est
pas le sujet il n'a pas fermé la porte
j'ai jamais demandé qu'une porte s'ouvre
si j'étais nationale j'ai demandé
l'unité nationale ce qui est tout à fait
autre chose que les ralliements
je ne me suis jamais prêté au ralliement
la classe politique se soit de gauche de
droite vous refuse pour l'instant cette
unité nationale oui mais très bien qu il
la refuse mais il faut bien qu'ils aient
devant le pays quelqu'un qui porte
l'essentiel sans compromission à la
question souvent posée est ce que vous
voulez entrer au gouvernement
ma réponse est non la papouasie ben
c'est bien à la question souvent posée
est-ce que vous accepteriez une
responsabilité que le gouvernement vous
confierez ma réponse est non on n'est
même pas la légion d'honneur
eh bien oui est ce que les actionnaires
est-ce que vous acceptez d
des récompenses des distinctions ma
réponse est non
le la figure à laquelle je crois est
celle d'un homme politique indépendant
capable de défendre devant leur pays
l'essentiel de son avenir sans
compromission d'aucune sorte sans
compromission un d'aucune son
indépendance
comme à chaque fois on vous pose cette
question indépendant mais seul il va
bien falloir également pour les
prochaines élections européennes les
honoraires louise harel est ce que vous
allez vous avez vous envisagé toujours
de faire des alliances peut être avec
lui des artistes rassemblement comme
vous voyez lulu dit le pape
vous savez la différence qu'on avait
avec lui des lycées que lui d y disait
il faut que le centre soit toujours à
droite c'était ça le point moi je pense
que si le centre que le centre doit
accepter d'être au centre mais tous les
rassemblements sont bienvenues puisque
je plais de l'unité nationale je vais
pas avoir le ridicule de descartes et
avec condescendance des gens qui sont
les plus sur l'échiquier politique les
plus proches
je je voudrais très souvent qu'ils aient
des attitudes qu'ils soient des
attitudes de deux de résistance à la
bipolarisation dangereuse bon mais en
tout cas je peux évidemment travaillé
par les construire avec eux je suis à
pau c'est ma ville j'en suis élu depuis
longtemps et bien la peau je rassemble
tous ceux qui pensent que la
municipalité actuelle ça ne marche pas
j'essaie de les faire ensemble entre
autres il ya beaucoup de gens de gauche
il ya beaucoup de et ça n'est pas avec
moi vous comprenez je suis pas en train
de dire
ralliez vous à mon panache blanc comme
un modèle historique que j'ai beaucoup
aimé terminer 4es et que impôts on
connaît bien je suis pas en train de
dire ça je dis écouter réfléchissez si
vous voulez un succès alors il faut se
rassembler si vous voulez réformer la
france
il faut se rassembler le problème est le
même si vous voulez pas de réforme pour
l'instant lyon pour l'instant il n'y en
a pas en ce sens une vraie forme alors
certaines sont sympathiques
compétitivité dans le bon les retraités
très très très oui pour l'instant ce qui
se passe entre budgétaire
jean marc ayrault seul flop pour la
première fois depuis vous avez essayé
depuis longer tenté c'est un sujet
d'actualité
jean marc ayrault se flatte d'avoir fait
reculer les dépenses de l'état d'un
milliard et demi pour la première fois
depuis 1958 et il vivra ben j'ai eu je
croyais que fillon avait dit à peu près
la même chose au gouvernement dont toute
maîtrise des dépenses est bien mais le
rapport que jlm ou carrese ump qui est
quelqu'un de très respectable à mes yeux
le rapport que gilles carez déployer
c'est pas du côté des dépenses qu'ils
allument surtout leurs larmes
ils disent et les recettes qui
s'effondre pourquoi ces des recettes qui
s'est fâché non parce qu'on a un pays
qui a perdu ses forces de production et
donc de ce point de vue là il ay la
raison d'allumer les signaux et alertes
les plus exigeants voilà on termine
quand même sur le budget d'état on avait
commencé par l' affaire tapie donc ce
sont les deux sujets sur lesquels on
trouve flatter d'avoir une un précurseur
je me flatte pas c'est vous qui le dites
dans votre roman
merci merci à vous merci perrine à la
semaine prochaine notre invité sur l ump
laurent wauquiez bonsoir à tous et à
très vite
il